cette visite de maison n'est pas tout à
fait comme les autres
cette nouvelle demeure a été aménagé
pour accueillir des parents avides de
concerts par exemple
grâce à cette baignoire pour bébé les
familles pourront apprendre les règles
d'hygiène c'est vraiment un lieu
d'éducation pour me connaissent et actif
en soit les parents on les accompagne
rachel travaille dans un centre
d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile
elle est venue découvrir ce nouveau
dispositif un partenariat pourrait être
créé je pense que quelque chose à faire
est ce qu'après en plus ces parents-là
pas responsable son statut et ils sont
amenés à vivre dans la nièvre donc dans
ça peut être si ce sens inverse ils
peuvent venir là ils auront un endroit
où ils peuvent apprendre parce qu'il
vient des pays étrangers
là bas on n'a pas les mêmes la même
éducation on n'a pas les mêmes mêmes
codes donc ça peut être un plus pour
tout est fait pour rendre les pièces
chaleureuse l'anonymat est respecté et
aucun parcours administratif n'est
enclenché objectif mettre à l'aise le
parents pour qu'ils ne se sentent pas
jugé il n'y a pas de mauvaises enfants
n'y a pas de mauvais parents il suffit
juste de trouver un équilibre
voilà et parfois on a besoin d'une aide
pour trouver cet équilibre et je pense
que nous on peut apporter ce truc c'est
la vulnérabilité économique fragilité
psychologique et problématiques sociales
sont nombreuses dans la nièvre pour le
conseil départemental en charge de la
protection de l'enfance
cette maison est un outil de prévention
indispensable ça permettra
qu'effectivement on arrive le plus en
amont possible
ça s'adresse à tous voilà tous les
parents le constat qu'on fait c'est
plutôt que de se laisser enfin d'être
isolé avec ses difficultés ou ses
questionnements
c'est un lieu qui se veut d'accueil
d'écouté
cette maison de la parentalité fait
office de test si les résultats sont
positifs à nevers d'autres actions
verront le jour sur le reste du
territoire